tinguished rector professors dear ladies
and gentlemen his students I hope some
students from Poland as well son today
student is polski vetem sorry Anna
bardzo ladna grappa vetem student
Dostoevsky so its students from Poland
are here so this is a additional hon
offa me dear friends I'm extremely glad
to be a guess of Columbia University
thanks for nice and very kind
introduction and first of all I would
like to thank you for this invitation it
is a source of great satisfaction to me
to be able to meet with representatives
of the United States intellectual elite
with the community that is sketching the
path of the future not just for America
but also for the entire world indeed
that is dimension of today's debate at
the world leaders forum i'm very pleased
at columbia university one of america's
most prestigious places of higher
learning is closely affiliated with
poland it was here that the Polish
Studies program was created two years
ago thanks to this program the research
is being conducted into Poland's more
distant and contemporary history and our
country has become much better known to
the American public opinion I would like
to thank cordially the authorities of
columbia university especially its
eastern european studies center for
supporting this wonderful undertaking i
would also like to thank the kosciuszko
foundation and the sample Polonia
foundation i hope that it will be
possible for the polish students faculty
to launch operations in the near future
at this renowned University which will
make our country even better known to
Americans
ladies and gentlemen do students to
notions have molded the most recent
quarter of the century of Polish history
freedom and solidarity today no one has
any doubts whatsoever that what happened
in Poland 25 years ago deserves to be
called a turning point the formation of
solid R&R solidarity in 1918 changed the
course of history and it initiated
changes throughout Europe the sowing of
solid our owners has led a bit not
immediately to a great yield in Poland
this took place in 1989 in the form of
their own table agreement between the
authorities in the opposition which
demanded Democratic changes consequently
the first non-communist the government
was formed immediately thereafter just
like a domino changes took place in
Easter Germany the Berlin Wall fell The
Velvet Revolution of cute in
Czechoslovakia changes took place in
Hungary Romania the Baltic States and
the Soviet finally the Soviet Union
disintegrated the Iron Curtain which had
seemed was supposed to have split our
continent asunder for eternity simply
and suddenly melted away the cold war
came to an end the processes of enlarged
Nick NATO and the European Union
demarcated a new era an era of openness
cooperation and integration Poland is an
excellent proof of the immense
creativity strength frida marbles the
greatest resource we had at the starting
point was human energy and creativity
the Poland of 1989-90 when we embarked
it on the path of transformation and
contemporary Poland are in
fact two different countries some
examples our gross domestic product has
grown over this 15 years by forty two
percent this is the greatest increase
among all the Central and Eastern
European states the earth of 2004 had
particular meaning as that was the year
Poland exceeded to the European Union
that was a time of truth for the
competitiveness of our economy the
results have proven to be spectacular
especially in terms of exports which
compared to the previous year have
spiked by more than thirty seven percent
the Polish economy has modernized it is
not just that it produces incomparably
more than fifteen years ago but at the
same time it also consumes one-third
less one-third less water one half less
coal with emitting ten times less dust
into the atmosphere living conditions
have improved considerable pause life
three years longer on average there are
four times more phone lines and three
times more passenger cars per 1,000
inhabitants we are experiencing an
educational boom UD students from Poland
are a good example of this educational
boom now in Poland we have 2 million
students in universities and that is
five times more than in 1990 nearly ever
other young Poland is studying although
we are still not a wealthy nation this
year's un report report ranks Poland
high in terms of living condition at
number 36 we are among most developed
nations of course and that is necessary
to on the line we also have problems we
must urgently create new jobs reduce
public Deb
and effectively reform the health care
system you will concur that this polish
challenges sound very familiar even here
in America and especially in Western
Europe we can see the problems which we
have challenges which we face amid
simply normalcy including all its
splendors and shadows but this normalcy
is really a measure of our
success dear friends ladies and
gentlemen the lodgment of the European
Union to include 10 new member states
including 8 from Central and Eastern
Europe marked with the experience of
communism become a great historical
event it is response to the a view of
the conflicts and divisions that Europe
once lived through while also being an
opening to new enormous opportunities
for development Poland today is actively
participating in the debate on the e
u--'s future this community of 25 states
which will grow to 27 in the near future
and certainly more derf after is a
complicated mechanism which must work in
a coherent and effective manner health
problem appear people sometimes even
speak openly of crisis however for some
who looks at the European Union from the
outside the sentiment of crisis may be
something incomprehensible or even
absurd Europe in the process of uniting
does not have any reasons to have
complexes or to be despondent despondent
its scorecard of achievement is really
impressive the countries that are
waiting to join the community also see
things this way after all they would not
all be knocking on the EU s door
if they believe that the life of crisis
awaits them there the reality of the U
is considerably better than the
sentiment prevailing within the process
of EU enlargement should be continued
that is the most certain recipe for
security stability and development for
all Europeans and the best that Europe
can offer to the world ladies and
gentlemen one of the most important
pillars of global security and stability
is the transatlantic bonds Poland is of
the opinion that the European Union
should continue with America to
strengthen this close and lasting
partnership only this will make it
possible to counteract global threats
and challenges effectively this model
reflects much better the idea of
international solidarity than a la carte
partnership calling for cooperation and
select issues at the same time we are in
favor on the EU esco accountability for
global security to be considerably
greater than to date Europe and America
may have different views and even
different interest in war on or another
matter experience shows however that
whenever we want we are capable of
reaching an agreement a perfect example
of this is the occurred in the issue of
jointly persuading the Iranian
authorities to disease from Iranian
enrichment program its achievement is a
good prognostic for further
euro-american cooperation in matters of
fundamental importance to the world we
have common interests I think that his
awareness is currently more firmly
rooted and both sides of the Atlantic
that just two or three years ago Europe
and America contribute toward politics
advantages
that are complementary not mutually
exclusive I think that people in regions
are afflicted with crisis or country
suffering under despotic governments
would have a hard time understanding why
we cannot combine our forces to provide
them with effective aid Europe needs
American and America needs Europe the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization is
also something that strongly bonds our
continents the Alliance has found in its
place in the new architecture of
security after the end of the Cold War
it plays an enormous role in integration
processes in bolstering stability and
confidence NATO's open door policy
should be continued because it serves
democratic reforms well in countries as
pie serves democratic reforms well in
countries aspiring to the alliance
listen gentlemen Poland fields cokin
table for the direction the matter stake
and not just in our vicinity not only in
the European Union or in the
transatlantic community but also in the
whole world I'm thinking now both of
problems that concern security as well
as of threaten ensuing from the absence
of sustainable development the essence
of today's word is interdependence II
and Poland has drawn its conclusions
from this we have not just fix our gaze
or our man ourselves we also look to
others seeing them as partners for joint
activities or as a person's to whom a
helping hand must be extended indeed
this commitment is the leverage that
elevates Poland's international position
our country has good relations with all
its neighbors polish soldiers have been
taking part in peace and stabilization
mission
for more than half a century and in
special way in recent years we know from
our history what the tragedy of war
external aggression the violation of a
nation's freedom and human rights and
the bitterness of isolation mean that is
why those who are currently living
through similar misfortunes can count on
polls we are in different places around
the world in those places where there
are threats of conflicts where citizens
have suffered at the hands of
authoritative regimes as well as in
those places where are smoldering ruins
people are attempting to build a
tranquil existence a new Polish soldiers
bring support and hope in Afghanistan
and in Iraq in Syria and Lebanon in
Kosovo Macedonia in Bosnia and
Herzegovina our response to global
challenges takes the form of support
provided to more impoverished nations
and the participation of Polish services
and non-governmental organizations in
humanitarian operations ladies and
gentlemen dear friends in conclusion I
would like to say the idea of solidarity
was not born in Poland it is an eternal
idea that goes to the core of what is
best in our humanity nevertheless the
poles were the ones who introduced it to
the circle of political values who
transformed it into a social movement
capable of changing reality today this
is our great message addressed to the
entire world at this time I would like
to mention chaso of me wash who died one
year ago a great poet a winner of Nobel
Prize for Literature sage who spent 32
years of his long life here in the
us he lectured and American universities
me wash was partially one of us and
partially one of you he embodied the
fulfillment of the American dream
coupled with innocent longing for his
lost homeland he investigated the
intricate path of the history and
culture of our times his great humanist
marauders follows in his moral treatise
i quote you are living here now he at
noon you have one life one point what
you manage to do will remain the ladies
and gentlemen let us do our utmost to
manage to do as much good as possible
for the world and for our joint success
let's ensure that our posterity is a
meaningful as austerities a meaningful
as possible let's build our court
openness cooperation among nations and
people let cherish solidarity thank you
for your attention